doug peterson has made the decision
early in the week and he's made it known
it will be jalen hurts not carson wentz
starting when the eagles host the saints
on sunday here's doug peterson when he
was asked why he's going with hertz over
wentz
quite honestly you know
we're not where we want to be as an
offense
we know that and
you guys have heard me say this a lot
around here in the five years that i've
been here and it's never about one
person and
um
you know we won a championship a couple
years ago with with a group of men and
and it's it's never about one guy and um
you know so i i looked at the whole
thing and and um you know decided that
that for this week and and uh you know
to look for that spark again to to try
to get the
the team over the hump to try to get
um
everybody playing better right and and
obviously the quarterback position is is
included there so uh that's really the
decision that i came to
um you know moving forward this week
man i i it
it feels like it was a long time coming
they gave carson wentz every chance to
prove that he could find his way out of
this mess play his way out of this mess
make that one throw that it seems like
he's been wanting to make that will
justify every decision the eagles have
made that has pointed toward him
drafting him keeping him paying him
and he's out of time that's it they got
to see what jalen hurts can do
congratulations jaylen hurt she gets to
do it against the saints defense yeah
right i mean yeah
what would he do you get to play the
hottest defense in the game right now
he's been kicking everybody's butt but
maybe that's part of the reasoning too
maybe that's where you know doug
peterson looks at it and goes hey the
stuff we've been doing
and you know the offensive attack we've
been approaching each game with and the
way carson went we got no chance if we
play that way in this football game well
listen i've been saying this since
monday i thought this was the right move
i do you know one it's just the the
pylon effect for carson wentz right now
it's all everybody talks about and
especially in philadelphia i mean darius
slade gives up a touchdown on a 50-yard
bomb they go oh carson wentz you know i
mean it's everything it's carson wentz's
fault for everything so there is that
issue we've talked about it i do think
he's beaten down by the pressure the
scrutiny everything about that and
yes the offense does stink and maybe
jalen hurts can give that spark right
and just a little jump start to that
eagles offense and a schematical
advantage to where the saints go
we don't know exactly what we're going
to see this week and the approach and
everything like that but i think doug
peterson's right too mike and saying
you know this is more than just one guy
i still i'm gonna stand strong with that
too i know it hasn't been great with
carson wentz but man i watched the film
back of that game against green bay the
other day there wasn't he didn't do
anything like it wasn't like oh wow
people are wide open
and the times he did get sacked there
was one maybe where you go get the ball
of your hand but other than that you go
he didn't really even have time to get
the bot of his hand it collapsed so fast
and all of that so um you know
good for them to make the decision and
this is the last thing mike sorry
with jalen hurts okay yeah you get the
schematical advantage maybe it gives you
the juice or the team maybe it all goes
good and great but if it doesn't and it
fails then you could just tell everybody
in philadelphia to shut up and now we're
going back to carson wentz and look this
guy's not ready yet it doesn't mean he's
done forever but he's not ready so i
think it does a number of good things
for the eagles right now as far as
making that move
yeah to the extent that carson wentz's
confidence was shaken by the decision to
pick jalen hurts because there's a
concern that he's going to be supplanted
at some point by hertz maybe the benefit
is go ahead and do it and if hertz fails
maybe wentz gets back some of his
confidence if hertz thrives then you
know he's the guy it's kind of a no-lose
outcome right when you're in a no-win
situation if you're the philadelphia
eagles there are questions though about
what the plans are going forward for
wentz that was an exchange that happened
yesterday when doug peterson met with
reporters let's hear it
in the big picture here what is the plan
with carson wence do you see him as a
quarterback you get get back to that
elite level that we know we can play at
i do and i know he will and um you know
i still have a lot of belief and a lot a
lot of faith and trust in in carson and
and uh as i've said this is not about
one guy we have a lot of things to fix
offensively but but i do believe that
carson
uh will uh will will will get himself
back to uh you know that championship
level
yeah
that's what you have to say yeah what
else we don't know what else you're
going to say because you're either
keeping him or you're going to try to
trade him either way you want to boost
him because if you are going to try to
move him you want other teams to believe
what you're saying and this really is a
strange window for carson wentz this
annual december 8 to december 10 window
let's go down memory lane here briefly
december 10 of 2017 is when he tore the
acl in a game at the los angeles rams
december 9 of 2018 is when he suffered
the back injury that ended his season
early and now december 8 2020 he's
benched for jalen hurts so uh seasons
going off the rails for carson wentz
three of the last four years the only
difference is last year is when they
were five and seven
and he rose up and carried a bunch of
no-names to the playoffs which made it
harder for him to placate people this
year because the most recent memory is
carson once was able to do it with no
help in 2019. yeah well i mean yes that
that was the greatness of carson wentz
you know and then you know again of
course the year they won the super bowl
he could have easily been the mvp of
football that year so it's been yes up
and down as bad as up and down as you
can i can remember with like a young
quarterback or anything like that
and that's why
you know mike as this has happened and
you think about this more over the last
week i just go the jalen hurts pick at
the second round was one of the dumbest
picks of last year's draft it's just
dumb i mean you really have it made no
sense to really help your football team
out it makes no sense and you traded
picks to draft a quarterback at number
two and you've paid him all this money
and then he's already dealt enough with
the injuries and the nick fole stuff and
izzy the guy and all that and then hey
let's bring in another guy to question
it now so we can so we can really
question if he's the guy and let's bring
a guy in from who played at alabama and
oklahoma so all the fans out there who
know nothing they'll still want to see
him play because they're going to go
wait he was at alabama and oklahoma and
he won and so we need to play him as
soon as carson wins struggles it made no
sense organizationally that pick the
more and more you think about it
anything about it it made no sense and
the eagles have nobody to blame but
themselves for this situation they're in
right now and the pressure of carson
wentz and the city and everything around
him
that that was done by the eagles it
really is they they put themselves here
so let me flip it around though yeah i'm
gonna flip it around
because we saw what happened with aaron
rodgers after the packers took a
quarterback we saw how he reacted right
the pack and the packers traded up in
round one to get jordan lopez sure and
yes he wasn't happy about it and we know
he wasn't happy about it brett favre was
his surrogate to the media early on to
make it clear he wasn't happy but when
it was time to show up and play he
channeled that into something positive
and you know chris we've talked about
this in different contexts but i look at
it this way
if carson wentz can't handle having
jalen hurts as his backup if he can't
handle that
can he really handle championship
caliber football can he handle
championship caliber pressure can he
handle the expectations that are going
to be forced upon him going into 2020 21
22. if he can't handle having jalen
hurts there
what can he handle and i i that that's
where i'm concerned maybe the idea was
let's let's apply a little heat
and see what happens well i mean
was it not hot enough last year when
they were five and seven and he had to
like carry the whole organization no why
that wasn't pressures were low i mean
because they stink we stink everybody
was bagging on him last night and
everybody
everybody was saying the same thing
though until he went on the run oh
carson wentz he stinks they should have
never let go of nick foles and then he
carried the team and nobody could say
anything because they were like whoa he
is the team so i think that was answered
already he's not aaron rodgers aaron
rodgers is established as one of the
three or four or five greatest
quarterbacks in the history of football
if he just walks away right now so
that's a different scenario there and
their team is a lot better than
philadelphia as we know so that's where
i just don't necessarily agree with that
pick now you're right carson wentz can
he embrace pressure
the city of philadelphia and all that
definitely you know me remember a few
weeks ago it bothered me that he had no
idea that doc rivers was fired by the
philadelphia 76ers you know it's one
thing to like shut out the noise it's
one another thing to live under a rock i
would tell carson wednesday like hey man
embrace philadelphia yeah you suck tell
them you suck and blah blah blah so what
who cares keep fighting they'll respect
you at the end of the day but the fact
that he's like closed the world out and
is kind of oblivious too i don't think
that necessarily is the right way either
we see other franchise quarterbacks
where you know they tell you hey i try
to block out the noise but they listen
to a good amount of noise to still know
and motivate themselves
and know what the talk is out there
about their football team that is one
little aspect that bothers me and uh i
mean you know maybe you're right mike
maybe you're right about that aspect
we're going to see how he handles the
situation i'm just saying they didn't
help it with that second round pick and
adding more pressure onto it with jalen
hurts who came from oklahoma and
everybody just sees them win and they
just go he must be great and you know
that's not necessarily the case
i'm still confused whether doc rivers
was fired or hired i've shut out the nba
so much well yeah i know you don't you
don't have to he was higher jay he was
hired no he was hired but yes okay but
you got my point
here's
something that shireen williams and i
kind of tripped over last night as we
were talking about it and i am ashamed
and chagrined that i didn't think of
this sooner because
when i look at the carson one situation
i look at his contract 25 million in
total compensation next year no one
wants him he stinks right now who wants
him who's going to take that
obligation on with another 15 million
that becomes fully guaranteed the third
day of the 2021 league year so you've
got a thin window there to dump him if
you want to dump him before you get that
extra financial commitment on top of it
and then it finally dawned on me yes his
offensive coordinator yeah that he was
on track to be the mvp and
what did the colts have at quarterback
for next year currently they have
nothing at quarterback for next year
phillip rivers signed a one year wait
for it 25 million dollar contract so
philip rivers
a year ago this would have been a
no-brainer in march if you say to the
colts you can have philip rivers for 25
million
or you can have carson once for 25
minutes oh what yeah
99.9999 percent of the population and
that's pretty much everyone except
philip rivers wife and kids
would have said a big part of the
problem
right right okay maybe 99.99 but uh but
they would have all said carson wentz
right yes and so i and people are you
know oh yeah it's crazy is he crazy i
don't think frank knows frank and here's
the other here's the other way to look
at it if the colts aren't interested
then no one else should be if frank
wright's not interested no one else
should be because reich knows him better
than anyone else yeah well i mean i
would be shocked if frank wreck doesn't
like him i mean i remember talking to
frank reich early in carson wentz's
career you know the draft process all
that he was a huge fan of him i think
it's a very real possibility it's a
great job by shireen connecting the dots
there and thinking that far ahead
because uh i could see that happening i
really could and who knows i mean i
guess i guess we're going to see how
this plays out here you know as far as
this last week of football but
i mean if if jalen hurts
just plays okay and they win a game
and
you know win a game maybe two i don't
know and it doesn't even have to look
good but they just win i mean
philadelphia is going to be in some spot
here i mean i i don't know where they go
or what they do because also
jalen hurts
i don't think is ready to be a everyday
nfl every game starter quite yet i don't
there were some good things he did last
week but there's some other issues there
too so
um philly isn't quite the predicament
and i i think we're gonna get a lot of
answers here in december
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports